did you ever almost walk away because
they're like well her part's not as big
as the others I'm sure they tried to uh
you know we're not gonna pay her as much
or did you put your foot down and go hey
man I'm getting ready for the second one
yeah many times I walked away from a lot
of offers really
my my lawyer and my
manager and agent they all thought I was
crazy and I kept saying no and they were
pushing me to say yes and I was like
really just like you did with that
manager you got up and you walked the
[__] out I I just kept saying no they
would bring me things I was like I just
I don't know why I I guess I had a
number in my head I knew what I felt
like they should pay and we got them to
that number and then my team was very
excited that I said no all the other
times yeah right
but because I didn't get paid on the
first one hardly like I think it was
something like
a couple thousand I don't know it wasn't
a lot and
it was it was nothing and strike on the
Iron's hot strike when the Iron's hot
you're like yeah you know you get like
15 minutes so you got to milk it
absolutely you never know this could be
it I'm done and if you got it you got to
get what you can from because they're
gonna take everything from you they're
going to try and give you as little as
possible that is just the way it works
well and I think every actor as soon as
they're done with a role if they don't
have another one lined up they think
that's it I'm never going to book
another role like I would always have
this anxiety when I would rap a movie if
I didn't have something else booked then
like I'm never gonna work again what's
you know and it you kind of like freak
out and you don't that's just part of
being an actor I think it's just part
all my friends said that they had that
feeling